okay let's do it again
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back once again to your
favorite podcast
[Music]
yes
[Music]
is
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
to another episode of riverwood griffin
i really appreciate you guys listening
every single week
uh i like all the new subscribers i like
you know everything that's happening
right now so i'm just gonna keep doing
this like this we keep doing the solo
episodes and
i really appreciate you watching
okay there we did it again riffing where
griffin is back at it
and i appreciate you guys like i say um
i do want to say uh
for the segment of when i do this uh
real world advice from a grown-ass man
you know i put a post up on instagram
and i just want to tell everybody i
really appreciate
all the overwhelming response i'm
getting all the messages people send
about the advice
and just all the people's questions i
wish i could get to every single one but
i cannot do that
so please i do try to read all of them
and i try to respond as best i can but
it is a lot
so please don't think that i'm ignoring
you i just i just
i just randomly pick sometimes or some
of the ones just really stick out to me
uh so i do appreciate that and i hope
you guys had a great week
um what's going on uh uh some things i
wanted to talk about well first
you know start with me uh so uh you know
so rachel moved in let's get
a relationship update i like to start
with those relationship update
so rachel moved in and she's trying
she's slowly bringing all her stuff from
her
other place and it's crazy okay because
you like i don't have no drawers all my
drawers are gone okay so she
take up all the drawers so we needed to
buy another dresser so
we bought this dresser right and then
you know like rachel's a girly girl you
know what i mean she's a girly girl she
don't like carrying a bag she don't want
to take the trash out she just doesn't
like spiders and like smells and she
just
just things about her i'm still learning
so you know
we get this big heavy box we got to put
the thing together ourself
you know and so
she goes i can put it together because i
have to leave i have to go do i have to
go do this
i'm doing this uh podcast i have to go
do a podcast and she's like i can i can
put it together
and i go okay you know what i mean
and it's so heavy we can't even carry it
upstairs and she goes don't worry i'm
just going to carry everything up one at
a time i go oh you are
so she actually filmed a stop-motion
video with her iphone of her
carrying it up and down just go putting
it and then she put most of it together
i had to help her tighten some screws
when i got back but i was like wow
this is just a [ __ ] boss [ __ ] right
here she
she she put that thing together and
it was great you know and we of course
we fought a little bit because she has
this thing where everything's my fault
but she's she's facetious about it i
mean you know she's being jokey but you
know like no matter what like
i'm looking at the instructions and i
move ahead and she's like stop going
ahead and i know what i'm doing
but it turns out i needed to go ahead
because she left some parts out like
these little pegs that were supposed to
go in
but other than that you know we had a
little spat we
i still helped her we worked it out and
the next day she told me how she didn't
tighten the screws tight enough because
the drawers weren't going in because it
hurt her hand
but she didn't want to tell me that at
the time but you know we worked it out
and now it's beautiful
and so you know that was like a fun a
fun thing you know it's like it's always
good to learn something new about your
significant other that you didn't know
or if you have some preconceived ideas
about them like i said she's a girly
girl and i was like oh
she's never going to be able to put this
thing together that was a stupid thought
of mine
she took care of that thing and it just
made me just love her even more
you know what i mean so that was dope
that's all that's really going on there
um so the nba you know so we had another
police shooting the jacob
i forgot the guy's last name i should
probably know these things before i just
uh
say them you know you know on
on the podcast like this yeah jacob
black
i think it was the guy's name yeah um in
uh
kenosha wisconsin was you know shot
seven times in a bag by the cops
don't want to go into a whole big thing
about this because i just have a
different idea
i have a different feeling about police
the police brutality or the situation
that's going on
i mean to me it just looks like bad
training you know it really does
like everyone likes to talk about what
should or should not happen in that
moment
so if you start at that moment ago well
this guy is resisting arrest and he's
saying something's in the car and then
the cops react
my problem is that it got to that point
like what's happening that it got to
that point that's where i feel like
the change should come you know
and then and then the use of lethal
force again
like what you know if if if you're at a
bar
you know like it's my buddy eric coke
he's a
ufc fighter he's trained in like five
different types of martial arts
box he can jujitsu all this stuff he's a
lethal weapon
if he's at a bar i don't care what
happens
if like it has to be so clear
what the other person is doing if
somebody's messing with him
for him to like have to jump in and do
something he will get in trouble
that just is the situation you know
that's why
you when you learn how to fight the
whole reason why you learn how to fight
is so you never have to fight
or you learn that you can't fight my
dude's a lethal weapon
if you saw a dude super trained in
fighting
beat up some drunk person you would be
like come on man yeah he was an [ __ ]
and whatever he did
but you have to know that come on you
got to be reserved with that you can't
just
use that you know because and even if
in a regular case even if like you know
how many times you just got into a
heated discussion heated argument
emotions get out of hand and you know
you
if you're that person with the lethal
force ability
you have to be the bigger person because
you can actually do some real harm
it's not the best analogy but i feel
like
the guns that the cops use when they get
to the lethal that's
their responsibility too like the fact
that it got to a point that he had to
shoot the guy seven times in the back
in front of his children the fact that
he got to that point
shame on those police shame on the
system
shame on all that listen and another
thing last thing about it
i can't stand this when you blame the
the person that they had to call the
cops on in the first place
that you blamed that person's judgment
the police needed to be called for
whatever reason
you know they knew that they when they
if they were on their computer they
uh they they must have known the guy had
warrants when they got there
or in the process of figuring out like
this guy he
he wasn't a model citizen so
now that the cops are there you want him
to all of a sudden start acting right
like that that's the ridiculous part
about it
like the reason why the cops are called
in any of these situations is because
there's something going on that is
escalated beyond control
so now the cops have to come and fix and
find a way to de-escalate this
not be the judge jury and executioner
de-escalate
so that's why i always go to there's
something going on
where we're missing something in the
training you know it's just like with a
driver's test how you have to go
and you have to take a test and they
don't even do that good enough but every
10 years whatever it is
maybe the police force they need to be
like okay let's put you in these awkward
situations
in a test situation so we know how we're
going to handle this
because this is happening too much man
it's happening too much so
anyways so because of the jacob black
the nba decide
they the nba is in the uproar like i
talked about last week with the nba
and then you know the protest see
nothing makes you feel like you're not
doing enough then when you're in a
bubble and you can't leave
like what has now been exposed is
all that [ __ ] is for show the black
lives matter on the court the t-shirts
the names on the jerseys
it doesn't affect [ __ ] it's just a
symbolic gesture
now it's a symbolic gesture that is
contained in sort of like a
a a prison itself you know they're just
locked away
and they can't do anything so the nba is
sitting there like what the hell do we
do
the milwaukee bucks decide we're not
going to play we're going to forfeit our
game
now i don't know what happened between
the time
milwaukee bucks decide they're going to
not play anymore
and then i read an article that the
lakers and clippers have decided they're
voting to not play the rest of the
season
to last night the playoffs are on and
the clippers are playing today
that i'm recording this podcast so i
don't know what happened with uh you
know
i don't know what happened all of a
sudden now
they just played uh you know whatever
yesterday we're gonna make isn't enough
look in my opinion the only thing that
really affects change is money
that's it dollars and cents man
you take when when income is starting to
get affected
by the powers that be that's when they
step in and go
yo we need to do something about this
and
what i don't understand is like the nfl
the nba
all these sports the sports that have a
predominantly black athlete
they have also a large amount of money
to help influence change how i don't
know
i'm not an expert but i just know that
there's a billion dollars in the nba
billions of dollars with the players
money combined
you know that's power and influence man
that's that's pound that's where you go
to you you
make sure that your vote you're uh
backing
the senators and congressmen and you're
making sure that there's
you know businesses and communities
taken care of i mean there's
there's ways to really make an effect in
the world other than wearing a freaking
jersey with you know
justice on the back of it you know so i
do appreciate when i see lebron james
talking about
voting and the nba saying like hey we're
going to open up the stadiums for voting
and
like all that kind of stuff that's gonna
affect real change
all the symbolic [ __ ] i don't know but i
just don't know what happened i i
i just i found it to be very strange
that like again money moves the needle
so one day that all the players are like
we're not gonna play
and then it seems like a week later the
games are back on and we're going
you know because i really think i really
think they realize
wow we stand to lose a lot of money and
playing or not playing what is it gonna
do personally
they i feel that they should play so
they have that voice every after the
games
you know doc rivers gave an impassionate
speech i think that resonated with
people
i think every time the the players talk
afterwards if they say
okay the game was good but hey let's get
justice for brianna taylor or
hey let's make sure you go out and vote
uh let's make sure that you know we
we uh praise the good cops out there
let's not demonize all the police
you know i wish that you know they would
come like that i loved what doc rivers
said that he said his father was a cop i
mean you know
i have friends that are cops man i worry
about my friends out there that are cops
i mean
not all cops are bad it's not all the
cops are not every single cop wants to
go out and kill a black person you know
but that's the kind of thing that we put
out there so if these nba players and
nfl players can go out
at the forefront of every time they're
talking and there's and you know after a
while that message is going to kick
in after a while you know it could
possibly make change i mean look at
the redskins is now no longer the
redskins the washington football team
they're getting rid of the redskins
because
you know finally the corporations were
like yeah enough of people that buy our
[ __ ]
don't like this so hey man change it and
this is a guy that was like he's
check us out he's a billionaire a
billionaire
and they made him change you know this
billionaire
they said to him yeah you're gonna have
to you know change this and he's like
oh how much money do i stand to lose now
it's gone
they changed it and he was one person he
said i'll never change this
so money talks so we got to find a way
to move the needle that way
so there's that
don't really have too much going on this
week about you know a lot of stuff i
just
there is the one big thing that i didn't
want to talk about and i actually have a
friend of mine that's going to come on
and
hit me to some stuff to really help me
understand it better but this whole
thing happened with bella thorne you
know so bella thorne goes on only fans
and she makes a million dollars
i see this you know this is how i before
i bring my friend on i this is how i
casually knew about it i heard like well
a thorn went on
and made two million dollars and i
thought good for her i it just made
sense to me
you know it's like you know it's like
sex sells you know
uh it is what it is she's hot
22. we know her she's you know this sexy
woman and
she decides hey i'm going to start an
only fan what i didn't know was like
apparently it was like research for a
part or whatever
i don't know to me just as a casual
person looking at twitter
i thought to myself damn is this how
it's gonna be and to me i thought
my first thought about it was well this
makes sense like forget hollywood
like everybody's putting a middle finger
up to hollywood you know
why should they be in charge you know
it's like so at first i thought well
here's bella thorne
like you know every movie she has to be
in she has to be some sexy sex symbol
person so now she can like write her own
ticket
so she's like so why should i go make
you know whatever her salary is for some
you know blockbuster movie where she has
to be like a
tart in the movie or i have to be sexy
in a movie or i have to have some love
scene in the movie
make whatever money she's making and
then like the people that make the movie
the producers and directors in hollywood
and
and the people that are you know the
advertisers and all the stuff that goes
into making a movie
they make more money than she does off
her so she said
[ __ ] y'all i could just be naked on my
own [ __ ]
and make make direct to consumer
provocativeness that's what only fans is
so that was my initial
introduction to it uh i i was like wow
then all this hate came everybody was
like [ __ ] bella thorne
you know all this tweets and stuff about
bella thorne just like
she's you know and i didn't understand
it i didn't understand it so
i asked a friend of mine who was an
influencer and she
has an only fan's account you know she's
like listen
there's a lot of women out there that i
know personally who
the uh quarantine hit jobs went away
uh you know some of them trying to be
entertainers
you know they said well you know what
sex sells uh i got to go on only fans to
pay my bills
no hate here do you and this is uh one
of those people so
here is my friend lindsay
demiola demonola demonola
did i say it right did i say it wrong no
you said it wrong
how do you say it demiolo
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
podcast
understand what's going on with the
bellator situation my good friend miss
lindsay demiola lindsay lindsay has been
an influencer in her time
uh she's created an app the 1888 app for
taking pictures
and she also has been on only fans
so uh lindsay thank you
for coming on i really appreciate it so
i'm just going to talk as somebody that
i don't know what the hell is going on
because i don't understand it okay okay
so
bella thorne decides to join only fans
she's famous and you know she makes two
million dollars
the next thing you know uh only fans
changes their policy and everyone's an
uproar the whole internet is [ __ ]
bellathorn [ __ ] bellathorn from all the
um sex workers are you is that is that
the proper term you want to call is it
sex worker
um yeah i believe that's the proper term
okay
um and even even before that let's just
let me just
start even with that right there see i
i've
i'm old school so i come from a time
where
you know sex work was very much
demonized
and you know it's just like hookers on
the street you know what i mean
and then it's you know so you know it's
it's hard to deal with like how
different it is right now in terms of
like webcaming and all this kind of
stuff and people doing their own thing
but at the same time though i think i i
think of sex work like i think of a
casino
you know gambling's fun but there is a
part of it that
is it can be seedy and shady i mean when
you have a casino in a place that
there's crime
around it it causes some other issues
and so i feel like sex work also causes
issues too you know you know if we live
in a society where
we're constantly talking about don't
objectify women but this is exactly what
this
is you know and so as long as you're
using sex to sell things people will be
objectified and it's not just women you
know it's like calvin klein
male models same kind of thing so anyway
starting from that place
so here we have only fans and if people
don't know what only fans is it's like a
private
uh website right private app and website
subscription based
service yeah subscription-based service
so uh
man or woman such as lindsay here could
she could have uh
subscribers they pay a certain amount of
money per month just like patreon
actually just like paid it's pretty
close to patreon but it doesn't really
have tiers you can't set up a tier
system
but there are other ways to make
additional money through
the platform itself because i know
patreon is
kind of tiered out i don't really know
patreon that well to be honest
but it's the same concept just like
twitch also
people subscribe but on only fans the
the big sell for only fans is that it's
a lot of provocative erotic content
that's basically basically
the the main point why i feel like it
was created in the first place
except it wasn't okay well fill me in
yeah so as far as i know i mean i've
only been
on only fans since the end of
end of march beginning of april so it
hasn't or no
beginning of may end of april is when i
started mine
so it hasn't been that long but
i do know that only fans started as
a platform that was just like strictly
subscription based for anything
and when sex workers realized how how
great it would be
for that purpose that kind of blew the
app
up to what it is now so it wasn't
it wasn't technically intended for that
as far as i know and then
because of everybody yeah because
everyone realizing like how how easy and
great it was
for that specific thing um
that's kind of what uh blew it up to
what it is now
okay so i okay boom so there we have it
so
now we have this and there's women
making tons of money i mean you hear
about this all the time i mean people
are
some people are making fifty thousand
dollars a month i'm sure that because of
quarantine and all that that was
you you've said that was part of the
reasons why you you went on it it was
like why not yeah i was just
bored i was bored i had friends who had
been telling me to do it for years and i
was just like no
no no and then
i finally was like i mean if i i don't i
couldn't have more time on my hands
so i was like at least i'll have the
time to like put in the work
okay because that was the big thing for
me got it so
what that's that being said all right so
now bella thorne goes on
this 22 year old she's very attractive
actress famous
she goes on and nothing blows up she
makes a bunch of money
and my feeling on it is like you know
why not you know it's like okay
if you're famous and you can make that
much money uh sending out you know
lingerie picks or whatever she's putting
on there fine
so then
you know only fans claims that they
changed their
policy because of their returns that
people
cause she wasn't she wasn't actually
showing what she said she was gonna show
or
let you plea please explain it to me
because i don't understand it
okay so where you where you first
started
saying you know like if someone wants to
go on the app and make all that money
like great i don't see a problem with
that so lindsay had a dog situation and
now she's back
he won't stop barking so so you were
saying about
uh sobel so people so all right so
there's our perception that people
people are mad at bellathorne because
she made money but that's not why people
are upset
that's not why they're upset please
explain why people are upset at bella
thorne
so the initial thing is because
she jumped on this app
um under the guise that she was you know
doing
how i took it like market research or
social experiment
um which is a big thing in the sex work
industry is like
if you are gonna make like a mockery out
of it or try and do it for like
research or just to do it it's kind of
like
disrespectful to the entire community
i guess is the proper way to say it so
everybody found out that she was
apparently working on this movie or
documentary
or something with some director and they
were gonna
do something that involved only fans or
like her only fans
um and then you know she made one um
she did the thing she was apparently
charging 200
for a full nude photo right and
i mean obviously like there were people
who were paying for it and when they got
it they realized
it wasn't a fully nude photo so
i don't know i also i have no idea how
long she was on the app i have no
idea um apparently it was just one day
if okay so the the big thing is like
only fans has a policy where like if you
spend money
and you've been scammed they will charge
it back to you
so let's say just for fun 100 000 people
you know pay 200 to see her naked
they get a picture and she's just in
like she's not naked they're not getting
what they said they're not getting what
they wanted
so they're allowed to charge it back so
it caused this whole ripple effect with
the entire
like inner workings of the entire
platform
as far as i understand because there was
there was a bigger limit
for tipping and for like the private
messages
and i personally um
don't really do anything that would be
more than the parameters they have set
now but i have friends who do
so it's like a huge inconvenience for
everybody else
specifically with that because when i
first started i know like
80 i don't want to say 80 but like a
huge chunk of like the income from only
fans usually comes from those private
messages
and the tips not so much the
subscriptions themselves
so to put a limit on that kind of [ __ ]
with the whole
flow of everything and then
you have the whole you can't
um do payouts once a week now
and i personally have it set weekly just
because
but i do know that there are a lot of
people that have like all of
all of their financials set up so like
they know they're getting this much this
week and then they just
split it up based on how they're getting
their deposits and
now with it being at the end of every
month it's kind of like [ __ ] with
everyone else's
system of how they okay okay but i also
understand
so if i'm playing devil's advocate only
fans side of it is that
listen if if they're returning
200 to 10 000 people because there's
probably a number like that
if they have to return to and so there's
like service fees and things that
they're being charged
and it happened all at once like that so
so so then okay so you're saying then
that you think that the people are mad
not because she was on there and making
money because good for her
right power i mean it's like whatever
yeah it's kind of like when britney
spears went to vegas
she made vegas like oh this is now it's
not just old acts and like
vegas acts oh super pop acts can go to
vegas and people will come
so that so actually bellathorn could
actually have helped only fans
by being like look even a celebrity is
on here and it like it takes away the
it's not as demonized as it was but what
she did
so they're really upset about the scam
part of it exactly because it was great
that somebody of her caliber was like
i'm gonna do it and you know
destigmatize sex work and break the
stigma i'm gonna do
all of those things but you she just
ended up
scamming everybody out of private
messages
and i mean i'm just i have a text in
front of me
when i was talking to one of my friends
yesterday and um
the biggest issue for everyone is that
she's doing it from a privileged
perspective when she created and only
fans because we know that she's
you know celebrity status white woman
who is like oh you know i can do this
too
which is great that's fine you know
that's totally incredible
but she doesn't know what it's like for
the survival
of actual sex workers and what they all
go through on a day-to-day basis whether
it's harassment or stalking or any of
these
i mean i guess she does but like not at
the capacity that these people who are
not celebrity status go through
um and
one of my friends was saying that a lot
of people are saying the stigma
has kind of been made worse because she
ended up
scamming everybody which ruins the
credibility of all sex workers
you know because now everyone's like
okay these these people are on only fans
to scam and it's
that's not the case but now she's the
model for that
okay well here's my well true enough but
here's my question then
so why doesn't
is only fans the only site doing this
um honestly i'm not sure i know because
what i'm saying is like they don't they
what are they cornered the market on
being an online brothel
you know a vid a visual brothel like can
someone else
come up like like if bella thorne really
wanted to make some money or help people
out she should just create her own
sort of only fans get all these sex
workers to come on and say
you know you get unlimited and you know
you can get money whenever you want
and she could you know or or someone
else could do that
i mean why why all this big uproar about
this one thing
why is only fans cornered the market on
this
i think it was just the the fastest
growing between everybody and like the
easiest to use and the most effective
when it came
to everything everyone knew it was like
a secure
um a secure platform when it came to you
know transactions and just like dealing
with privacy and all of these other
things
so i think that everyone just kind of
flopped to it because it was like the
place to have an account and
um yeah i think i think that's why it's
just
but don't you think don't you think that
she's famous enough to
if she if she wanted to do that or or
anyone that because of the publicity of
this
couldn't anyone come out and be like hey
only fans is
messing with such sex workers and and
and uh you know taking away their income
and making it hard for them hey i got my
new platform on here
oh you know only whatever or you know
people only
or you know sex work is good.com or
whatever it is
why couldn't someone else come up with
that do you remember like eight or nine
months ago when there was some app
trying to beat
the new uber and lyft ah right nobody
ever heard anything about it again
right so you think it's like that same
concept
if you have all of these people on one
platform
it's it's not necessarily easy to get
everybody off it to go somewhere else
just like with anything you know i get
it i get it well listen i just i really
i
i'm glad you came on i appreciate you
being you know open and honest about
like you know your
your own situation with uh you know be
even being on it and
i guess there's a cute dog
you know and it's just i just didn't
understand because it was it was like
blowing the internet up
everyone's talking about it and then you
see all these like messages about you
know [ __ ] her [ __ ] her and it's just
why you know people don't know why so
you gave me a different perspective on
it and i appreciate it
and the only the last thing i want to
share too is like to speak again on like
the privileged perspective that she has
two things actually um if she wanted to
tell a story
and do some sort of documentary you
could have chosen literally anybody on
the platform to get an actual like real
raw perspective
instead of being in your in her position
and deciding that she was gonna do it
herself
you know what i mean um and also
she had tweeted something yesterday she
tweeted some apology and at the end she
said she was having a meeting with only
fans
and that just made it worse because
actual sex workers including myself i
needed to use support a couple times and
it's strictly automated responses and
sometimes they take longer than a week
to reply so it's just like it speaks to
the privilege of everything where like
i have friends who have been waiting
months for like support help for like
actual actual real issues and bella
thorne makes one
phone call because she [ __ ] up right
yeah she's bella thorne so she gets to
talk to them personally and fix it and
obviously like i'm not stupid i know
that
a company like that or even just like
any company in general
isn't in a position to like reach out to
people directly but
also you give automated responses that a
celebrity says
oops and now you're having meetings and
she's trying to reverse everything when
if you're for me it's like if your
intentions were pure
and you wanted to do the work that you
said and you wanted to tell this story
and you wanted to help
break the stigma you could have chosen
literally anybody else in yourself or
send out the naked picture yeah or
actually send out the naked photo if you
want to be a part of it be a part of it
you know exactly like but it's also it's
hard for me to say that because like i'm
not naked i'm my only fans
yeah but like everybody knows that yeah
exactly everybody knows that and
sometimes like i'll do a little bit more
than that and then i'm like surprised
[ __ ]
but i i'd like you know nobody's out
here scamming like that
unless it's like a catfish account or
your bellathorn
got it well that yeah okay well that
makes sense now i get why
you know i get why everybody is upset or
at least i understand the perspective
that you're saying
you know but like i say i appreciate you
coming on uh this is lindsay
demiola did i say it right you did it
only took you like 16
drives lindsay how long have you known
me i know
too long but anyways thanks for coming
on riffing with griffin and i appreciate
you
uh giving me this time to explain this
all right
thanks a lot you're welcome yeah so i
mean there you have it
i don't know if i understand more now
than i did before but
you know it it is what it is um
you know i mean things have changed
you know it's like like i say like i was
saying to her back in the day
you know you thought of sex work you you
thought prostitute
you thought you know some
drugged out chick working the streets
and then
and then you might hear about high class
call girls you know there's all these
different names they've had
call girls hookers you know what
whatever the names that
you know and we just demonize it so much
but
i mean to me it's like i feel the way i
feel about it
you know it's like if you don't want to
be
if objectifying someone is wrong
that profession
that's the foundation of that profession
you can't have it both ways
okay you just you can't have it both
ways just just own it
that's all my thing is i just say just
own it i
you know it's like when i go to a this
is like i have material about this but i
can just just talk about it because it's
how i came up with it just thinking
about it it's like you know you go to a
restaurant
right you go to if you go to a
restaurant
i never understand when the waitresses
are dressed
super sexy it's like what ass and
titties
got to do about selling burgers
you know what it's like sometimes it's
just
overwhelming and distracting i remember
going i was in vegas at
one of these fancy rest it was like you
know one of the you know
uh whatever the one of those chef places
in it but it was like a burger place you
know
and at the waitresses i mean the dresses
were so tight two
sizes too small camel toe i was like god
damn this is like kids are coming in
here and then as a dude you're just kind
of like what am i supposed to feel
you know it's so crazy like listen i'm a
comic we at comedy clubs we make
people buy two drinks you know what
comes with alcohol
intoxication what comes with
intoxication
people lose their inhibitions people act
up sometimes you're gonna get people
who are acting inappropriately well you
know what comes with
that provocative ass sexy outfits
arousal
that's what it comes with isn't that the
whole reason why you're doing it you're
trying to make men
feel a certain way so they can be like
ooh i'm gonna tip you more because you
got your titties out
it's like but then we're like we're not
supposed to feel something
it's like bacon cookies if you're baking
cookies in the kitchen i'm gonna come in
the kitchen and be like
what's going on in here cookies smell
good and you might be like no no these
aren't for you this is for the bake sale
for the kids
okay my bad but it smells good now
listen of course i can't come in
and be like don't you be making cookies
you know what happens when you make
cookies i can't grab the spoon and just
start licking it you know i can't grab
the cookie dough i can't push her out
the way
and grab those cookies cause that's
that's that's inappropriate
you know that's inappropriate behavior
but hey hey don't be mad
that i like the smell of cookies you
feel me
so anyways
we do have to like stop demonizing
of sex workers but at the same time on
the other side
don't act like you do with something
that you you're not saving society
either okay you're not a peace worker
all right like i said to her it's like
a casino when you put a casino in a
neighborhood there's a lot of
negative negative stuff that comes from
that too along with there's jobs and
you know and then now people are
gambling but there's look people have
gambling problems
there's crime around casinos because of
the nature of it that's the same thing
with sex work okay
there's there's some there's a there's a
seediness also around it that can come
from it too
so so let let's let's not act like
like it's all roses that's all i want
it's just own own it and then we could
deal with it
as a society but let's stop pointing
fingers on either side that you're wrong
you're bad this is terrible and you stop
coming and being like
i'm i'm saving the world or like you
know you're not a peacekeeper
[ __ ] okay just
let's just be real about the [ __ ] all
right you know be real about
what is happening and there's a lot of
things
negative negative stuff comes in your
way too like lindsey was talking about
you know negativity comes like you get
stalkers you get people acting
inappropriate you get people treating
you a certain way
that it comes stems from that it's not
all gonna be
you know roses all right
[ __ ] okay
let's get to this now i got a lot of
them today so i just thought i'd get
right to it so ladies and gentlemen
real world advice from a grown ass man
hey and we're back with real world
advice from a grown ass man i got a lot
of good ones today so i just thought i'd
get right into it
so we can uh you know we can go to it
man
so this was a a heartfelt one this one
was a good one um
how do you rebuild your self-esteem
after an abusive relationship
i hate myself well damn
i mean this is a lot going on here i
mean first you already know you were in
an
abusive relationship so if you if
that's where you start with yourself and
go oh
this wasn't right this is a factor
while i why i feel the way i feel about
myself
now you do have to start the perfect
word you use is rebuild
you know you rebuild your self-esteem by
doing things that
make you feel good make you feel
confident i think it's time to work out
i think it's time to work on you i think
it's time to like
pursue those career paths that you
wanted to pursue find those
hobbies you know like whatever it might
be ceramics or
you know doing tick tock videos or
whatever it might be
you know you do have worth and value and
you have to find those things
that you are good at and excel at those
things or find something that you want
to
learn how to do because when you learn
how to do something
all those steps you take to to get
better at something
that builds your self-esteem and your
confidence look if you were with
somebody that was treating you like [ __ ]
that's why they were doing that they
were trying to control you and make you
feel bad and make you feel a certain way
about yourself
ah that person's gone from your life now
you have to fall back in love with
you who you are there's no reason to
hate yourself because that person hated
you or that person hated themselves
so they wanted everything around them to
feel the same way
you are loved you have family members
you have friends
and you just have to look in the mirror
and do those self-affirmation things i
am good enough i
am beautiful i am smart and then go out
and prove that to yourself you know it's
still it's those little things
sometimes the smallest thing
the smallest thing can turn out to be a
huge
influence in your life no matter what if
it's just getting up early in the
morning
making your bed clean you know cleaning
up
working out just even if it starts with
just a walk eating healthier
these are all things are going to make
you feel better about yourself
so don't let someone else's horrible
attitude
horrible opinions let someone else who
obviously has some problems with
themselves
dictate how you feel about you you
deserve better
you just have to you have to go prove
that to yourself
but don't wallow in self-pity either you
know don't sit around and be like oh no
the you know this person did this to me
at a certain point you got to take
ownership of your own life no more boo
who woe is me
it's like okay you deal with it i got
treated like [ __ ]
i'm having some issues and the fact that
you even reached out asking me for
advice or whoever you're asking for
advice
means that's the first step right there
because you're saying you know what
this doesn't feel right trust that
it don't feel right you want better for
yourself
so go out there and do it good luck
i can't get over my girlfriend who broke
up with me over a year ago
seems like i'll never heal well
i mean this is this is a this is like a
thing that we all have felt
love is what it is man when you feel
like you love someone
so much and they become the center of
your universe
and then that it's taken away you feel
like you've lost something but you know
what
you have to remember you in that
situation too a lot of times
like in my own personal experience like
when a past girlfriend
broke up me it really crushed me you
know she cheated on me
and you know it was a crushing thing
that i felt when we broke up
but one of the things i always regretted
was i wasn't working on me
i mean at the time i wasn't pursuing
comedy i just thought about doing
i kept saying i'm gonna do this but i
never did it i
wasn't i let i started to work and so i
wasn't
active and i just gained a bunch of
weight
so in the end i i woke up and i looked
at myself after i got broken up with and
i thought you know what i wasn't even
working on me
and i was encouraging her i was helping
her i was like
being a cheerleader rah-rah-rah but i
wasn't working on me so while she was
building herself
up turned to me and i look at myself
like i wouldn't want to be with me
either
and i said to myself i'm never going to
do that again
i'm always going to make sure i'm
working on me because that's
attractive make sure you are out there
pursuing your goals and dreams and
working on you
because that self-improvement is going
to rub off on the person around you and
it's also going to attract people
who want to be around that you know so
and if that person didn't see that in
you you have to see that in you and if
the relationship didn't work you're
going to know why it didn't work because
you probably weren't on the same page
so from the i you know i don't know too
much about this situation but this is
just general advice for people like
you know don't it's gonna happen you're
gonna get wrapped up in the other person
because love is what it is but make sure
you are looking out for you
make sure you're taking that care of
yourself mentally physically and
emotionally
so you are prepared for when things are
really great
and also when things are really bad so
it's time to get over this
chick man it's been a year she ain't
coming back
she ain't coming back bro and it's okay
get yourself out there dating apps
whatever it is but start with you
make yourself the best version of
yourself
so when you do go out there she gonna be
jealous when she see you again
because that's how you have to do it
there's nothing better
doesn't let me tell you something they
nothing better than revenge like
i wish i could see my ex right now at a
restaurant
i always want to walk in with rachel and
see my ex like oh hey
wow the years have done wow look at you
good to see you yeah this is my this is
my beautiful
uh younger than you girlfriend who
treats me really well
and uh you know we're gonna spend the
rest of our lives together how's
everything with you and that uh
that guy you uh cheated on me with who
had a wife and kids how's that going
you know what i mean is that going good
oh you know what i mean
just won't be a there's nothing that's
that's the revenge you want you want to
you want to be you know like i want to
be like oh
hey have you seen any of my movies that
i've been in oh how's that have you seen
my tv shows
you know you just want to be that's the
best revenge
it's just being the best version of
yourself you know and then
you know then you see her again and she
gonna be like well damn where was this
when i was with you
well you stifled me you know you know
whatever you
whatever your thing is use this [ __ ] as
motivation to be a better you
here we go hi eric i'm 37 year old man
who's having a bit of a mid-life crisis
i have a good job and a loving wife
i mean i don't know what to say to this
[ __ ] to be honest
you know you don't see you know what i
see in this
question is that you don't appreciate
the [ __ ] that's right in front of you
so you got to ask yourself what are you
do you think you're missing in life
like what do you think you're missing
and not doing
because you need to go do those things
because you have a great job and a
loving wife
like not everybody can say that so
if that's not enough what's going on man
like look at yourself in the mirror and
be like what have i not done have i not
pursued a dream have i not
have i not completed some goals do i
feel like this is not what i thought my
life was gonna be
you know then you have to get you have
to get past that [ __ ] or you have to
face it and deal with it you know
lean on your wife in these moments man
um admit listen oh man we all go through
it you know we all
have to accept that we're going to get
older but you know just getting older
doesn't mean you still can't get better
you know you know most men you make
the money you're you you're most
successful you know
late 30s and in your 40s because you've
built yourself up and now this is the
time you enjoy it so
you're right on track man and remember
you have a good job
and a loving wife like stop looking in
there
looking in your in your mind and
overthinking like well i wish i would
have done this or that
and really look at yourself and be like
can i actually accomplish other things
what do i think i'm missing from life
that i feel this way
because from the looks of your own
sentence you doing all right
so get your [ __ ] in gear
my boyfriend of four years doesn't want
to talk about marriage
but i do thoughts now this is
you know this is about the differences
between
men and women look guys
this is just some advice for the guys
listening right now
look women do have a clock they got a
clock
like how long do you think it takes to
get to
how about this meet someone fall in love
get married have children how long do
you think that that takes
what's the realistic the shortest amount
of time you think that can happen
you know a year two
i mean think about that you know you
have a clock
you know so it's like women you know
they they're not young forever
the older they get the harder it is to
have kids so
these are things they got to think about
so don't be scared by it so if you're
like say
25 year old girlfriend says hey are you
what's your future plans don't be scared
by that because in their mind they're
going well [ __ ] i'm 25.
we have to be in love we have to you
know we're gonna get married
we're gonna live our life a little bit
are we gonna have kids right away we're
talking about five
six seven year process she gonna be 32
are you gonna have other kids i mean
this is a lot women have to go through a
lot to have kids
just what about her career what about
her dreams and goals and aspirations so
when young so look you so what i'm
saying to you is
you have to understand that your
boyfriend just might be scared by all
this
we are just we get scared man we just
cowardly
about this sometimes we don't want to
think about like oh my god because we
we're starting to think about we're
moving ahead like oh my god i'm married
i'm handcuffed my life's over or
whatever
whatever thought whatever ridiculous
thoughts goes in their head just
reassure him that this is just you're
just like
hey is this something that you wanna do
i just wanna you know
because you're like i i wanna get
married and we've been together four
years
i'm such a such age and i just wanna
know what are your thoughts
you can make it sexy and fun and you can
make it nurturing
and you know it doesn't have to be like
a naggy thing it doesn't have to be
something where you're just like
but what are we doing because this is
you know you have to like
discuss it so he knows that this is
where your mind is and then there is
going to be a point in your life where
you're going to have to be like
yo i want a husband and
we are been dating so if it's not going
to be you we need to break up with this
[ __ ] because i got to go out here and
find a man
that knows my value and worth because
and i got to go to start doing that
because that [ __ ] takes time you know i
got to get on the tinder swipe
go on a couple of shitty dates you know
maybe the third fourth day i mean
look how long it takes to get to know
someone you know right it takes some
time so guys out there
don't be afraid when you're one when
your woman even someone you just met or
even someone you're casually dating
who's just
thinking about this because they have a
lot to think about
and ladies you know don't don't don't
scare the guy off
don't listen be aware that he's scared
reassure him okay we're children men men
sometimes are just especially young men
we're just we're just
we're so stupid so we need to be
spoon-fed
so just take it easy on him and talk
about it in
a fun casual way but express
your wants needs and desires and find
out what his are
and then see if they you know coalesce
because it might be
he might not be the one you know what i
mean or like i said he is the one and he
just you just made him nervous or he's
just
he's got thoughts about it like i had a
buddy of mine who's
whose parents got divorced and you know
his father is just a [ __ ] right
so he was scared to propose to his wife
because he was like
oh man i don't want to be like my dad
you know
so it's like you don't know what's going
on in your boyfriend's head or why he
feels this way what's his experience
with long-term relationships and
marriage and all that
so that's really when you get in depth
and you really find out about each other
so you can like see if this is the path
you want to go on right
so good luck my girlfriend of six years
gets annoyed at me easily
lately which leads to an argument is
this normal well you know it's not
normal that's why you're asking this
question
i mean it sounds to me like y'all are
having some issues you know sometimes
you know you after six years you become
the love is the love is different now
you know the infatuation's gone
now you're like you have to know who
each other
are and accept the faults accept the
good
good accept the good parts and accept
the bad parts so it sounds like you
you're not communicating enough anymore
so it's time to like really
get in there and find out what the hell
is going on because you know
sometimes you sometimes you just
you go through the motions thinking that
everything's okay and you don't check in
after six years man you gotta check in
check in with her and be like hey what's
up you know
how are you what's going on do you have
some
you have some thoughts uh you know are
am i doing okay you know you know you
guys
change you know you change over the
years and so you got to make sure you
get caught up with those
changes but no she shouldn't be getting
so annoyed with you
so instead of like don't put it on her
find out find out what she needs and
wants
why why is she getting annoyed with you
as a reason whether this
whether it's a valid reason or not if
you find out
why she's getting annoyed with you then
you can somehow deal with that situation
then you could deal with those it could
be something that could easily be fixed
you know it's like if she's annoyed with
like let me give you an example
rachel never liked she never liked she
don't want me liking people's pictures
especially
girls okay on instagram i don't like
people's pictures
she it bothered her all right now you
could be one of these people that you
get all annoyed it means nothing
i'm just liking what does it matter i
took the approach of like
okay i don't need to like people's
picture
who gives a [ __ ] this is how i like
pictures now on instagram
oh nice oh she's pretty you just you
know what i mean like you you don't have
to
actually press the like when you see a
billboard on the on
when you're driving down the street and
you see a billboard you don't pull over
stop
climb up on the billboard and put a
stamp on it like okay i liked this
no you drive by the [ __ ] and
when you look you go damn
that chick's hot or if you're whatever
oh that guy that guy's handsome whatever
your thing is
you don't always have to have some
physical like
real world response so my girl didn't
like me liking girls pictures
or following a bunch of girls okay i
just unfollowed a bunch of girls and i
stopped liking people's pictures
problem solved it was so easy to do if
that makes her feel better then do it
it could be something easy like that or
it could be something that you go well i
can't change that and then you guys can
actually start a dialogue in a
conversation
but you need to find out why she's
getting annoyed with you and then really
delve deep don't just stop at the
superficial things
like really listen and get in there
because sometimes people say something
and
and it might mean something else it
might it might be delving into other
issues so
communicate with your girl communicate
communicate communicate six years
i'm sure you still love her so it sounds
like it's worth
trying to fix all right good luck
hey eric this is elizabeth from
louisville kentucky and i'm just looking
for
some advice from a grown-ass man my
boyfriend and i have been dating
for about 11 years and we went to high
school together but
he is a couple of years older than me
and i just feel like
all of his friends from high school who
he still hangs out with from time to
time
just treat me like i'm still the young
person
in their group and just kind of make me
feel like i'm naive
and innocent and a comment is always
sort of made about me
whenever we get together so i'm just
looking for some advice on what to do
and how to deal with
your significant other's friends when
you don't always get along
all right so so the original question
and i asked her to send a video was you
know my boyfriend's friends treat me
like i'm naive because i'm a couple
years younger
and the quiet type okay well this is a
lot right here um
you know first of all you should have a
discussion with your boyfriend about
this and be like hey you know i don't
like how your friends are treating me
and you got to be firm about it in the
sense of like
he can't just dismiss your feelings you
have these feelings
and you can't be quiet about it you know
you get you have your quiet time you
don't like how it doesn't have to be a
confrontation you just got to be like
hey i'm noticing every time i go out
with your friends they're treating me
this way
and it's kind of getting it's kind of
getting annoying that they're saying
this because you need his support
you know because if he's like going
along with it
like that's a problem like because if my
friends are saying [ __ ] about my chick
trust me i'm gonna be the one to be like
yo yo yo
stop doing that she don't like it
because we talk about it at home and
it's causing a problem here so can y'all
cut that [ __ ] out i mean that's what has
to happen
and and but if these are like people
that you also consider your friend and
you guys hang out with a lot too
it's okay for you to be like hey guys um
i'm not i'm not in we're not in high
school anymore um this isn't the you
know the playground
you know we're not you you're not the
cool kids and i'm the other kid that
just got here
you know we're we're all equal here and
i'm i'm getting
it's kind of you're kind of bugging me
that you're saying this about me all the
time
you know you got you know you could say
it nicer than i would i mean i'm a
[ __ ] so
i i we that shouldn't be stopped
so you in your way have to just express
and it's gonna take a couple of times
it's going to take a couple times for
people to be like oh
okay my bad because your real friends
are going to be like oh i didn't realize
this was bugging you
even if even if they go ah come on we're
just messing around
you still got to be like yeah i
understand but it's starting to get on
my nerves like you don't understand it's
affecting me and i would appreciate
if you stop doing that it's okay to be
like that
but start with your boyfriend let him
know first
because you know he's a part of that
i'm just that's how i feel about it he's
a part of their feelings towards you
so you need to make sure he doesn't feel
that way
then once he understands how you feel
about it then you're going to take that
over to the rest of the group
and then you all be able to be like okay
you know and by the way
that's gonna show how nice how unnaive
you actually are
so you know don't don't prove them right
you know and being quiet is okay
being sensitive is okay people often
knock people like this like oh you're
stupid
you know sensitive people change the
world man the acting teacher told me
that
you know it's like comedians are very
sensitive people and we have to be
because we have to be
in we have to be in tune with life
because that's the that's you know we're
recreating these experiences
on stage you know we're emotionally
connected to material
i mean all artists are that way they're
sensitive that way so
when you're sensitive you know
it's okay because you're tapping into
some like real vulnerable emotions
and now you're able to like understand
things better tapping into that so
being quiet is fine don't don't make
people make you feel bad about that
but don't let them creep into your head
like
a feeling the way they think you are no
no you let them know
that's why it's even more powerful from
a quiet person that goes hey
stop doing that [ __ ] i think you're
gonna be okay
because the fact that you even reached
out to me and you sent me that video
you're not quiet type you know this is
something that's bugging you
so deal with it you know you don't have
to sit by and be like uh
take this just deal with it head on this
is your boyfriend
if he cares about you and loves you then
he needs to hear how you feel about
things
so this is how you will deal with things
moving forward because they're going to
be other issues
so when those other issues come up how
are you guys going to deal with those
issues
are you going to hold it in and wait
till you explode no you don't want to be
like that so
get that out there good luck
all right everybody that was another
episode of riffing with griffin
listen next sunday uh september 6
if you play call of duty warzone i need
you to click that link down below and
sign up for checkmate gaming
because we have my own tournament the
eric griffin gaming tournament is coming
so i want you guys to be a part of that
i'm gonna be commentating the whole time
so we want everybody to be streaming on
their own platforms and stuff and i'm
gonna
we're gonna be grabbing all those feeds
and i'm gonna be talking the whole five
hours of the tournament
you know so it's gonna be a fun thing
it's a 250 dollar prize
free entry so sign up at checkmategaming
on that link below
i would appreciate that and once again i
really appreciate you guys
listening to griffin with griffin um i'm
gonna continue with the solo episodes i
do have a big
interview coming up next week just
because i still like to interview people
too and this is somebody i've always
wanted to have on my podcast so i got
him coming next week
mr bill burr uh 99 problems but a bill
ain't one that's gonna be the name of
that episode
so thank you guys for watching we're
from with griffin and remember i i'm on
twitch daily
at eric griffin gaming and please uh you
know subscribe
share like tell your friends and
keep looking out on my instagram at eric
griffin for real world advice for a
grown ass man post because that's where
i i'm doing it
and you know thanks a lot guys and i
appreciate you listening once again and
i will see you
next week
you